[Music]
everyone leasing time here at Paris
games week we are here might be able to
tell in Sony's kind of behind closed
doors area tomorrow has just been
playing the Shadow of the Colossus
remake remaster to remake more than a
remaster is considerably changed and
also not very much changed features as a
fan of the classic ps2 game which is one
of the greatest games of all time in my
humble opinion I don't think you're
looking argument yeah I don't and if
they do like as no weapons no weapons no
mates I'll see you there
I don't think I think that's exactly
what fans of that game want they want
just touch up here and there I don't
want fundamental massive changes and
that's largely way is so I played the
first Colossus the third Colossus yeah
there was an option to play the fifth
one as well but we ran out of time and
it plays pretty much exactly how you
want it to play when I was playing it
there was actually one change that to
the controls that I only I didn't pick
up on but the person who was demoing it
or standing by me as I played it I asked
him I said there's something that feels
different about the controls I can't
pick up my ears and the only thing it
was is the jump button had been moved
from triangle to X and that's kind of
like a very natural change that no one's
it is I mean especially over the course
of gaming over the last 10 or so years
it just you don't really yeah just like
do you there he felt we need to justify
this and I was like dude you don't have
to but he was like it was X on the Last
Guardian which is why I changed and
obviously with games like Uncharted
which another Sony property jump is on X
so that's kind of like familiar and easy
for muscle memory that's the only real
change for the game itself in terms of
how it plays obviously it runs at a
consistent frame right now and
you can feel a lot of that I paid a lot
of share of the cost so kind of like the
way of clothes and the way kind of like
my muscle memory reacts it's kind of the
the performance of that game on PSN is
also burned into my muscle memory so I
know at what point to jump from that
kind of stuff did you play it on ps3 I
did not play on pier okay so I played
just the original one and it felt it
felt a little quicker
I didn't feel like I was messing things
up anything like that you can see in
some of the gameplay that we captured
and for the most part OnPoint there's a
few moments where I slip off and like
just time and grab very late for the
most part I ran the same because of the
consistent frame rate it feels like
wonder kind of picks up momentum a lot
quicker and I'll grow is still a bit of
a pain to control but it's one of the
things that I quite liked about that
game it adds an element of skill to kind
of like doing multiple things while
you're on auger like to put the sword up
and try to figure out where you're
supposed to be going and it also kind of
encourages you to micromanage when
you're doing showy stuff like standing
up on a girl while firing a bow and
arrow for example yeah so that kind of
felt good at the same time they didn't
feel too different yeah because you
can't change too much yeah you have to
keep it so it's all of it is perfectly
intact it's clearly been respected the
biggest changes visually yes and it
looks stunning like it looks really
really nice it looks like they've
clearly paid attention to the kind of
the kind of aesthetic and mood that they
wanted to get out of that the original
Team Ico team wanted from and the way
the Sun wanted from Shadow of the
Colossus and all all the kind of visual
representation visual updates I've had
that in mind and so like it feels like
there's a lot more fog in the area yeah
so like one of the things in the
original game was like there wasn't
everything was always clear there was
like a hero form for a haze to
everything and as you kind of go deeper
in the world that clears and because
everything is nicely sharper now on the
draw distances better
you kind of technically can make out
things but it seems like they've
increased the amount of fog so it's not
has that kind of like mystery in the
distance kind of feel to it which I
really really appreciate otherwise it
looks really really nice like a zoomed
in on Wonder's face for a bit and for
the first time you can actually make out
facial features which was really kind of
weird and awesome because usually it's
kind of like a flat texture in the
original versions but that was really
cool so like there's not much to say
about it I think the thing that like
stuck with me was I told the guy I was
speaking to you like it was like if you
play the game and you don't feel like
it's any different that's not a bad
thing that means we've done our job and
to me that's like that that ring should
you know kind of true for me that
resonates for me it feels the same it
plays the same it's still like
generating the same kind of emotions
when I'm standing yeah when I'm stabbing
a Colossus in his head so I'm really
really excited about this and yeah I'm
looking forward to get my hands on that
game alright well from more from Paris
games week make sure you keep your eyes
peeled to gamespot.com
save the colossi justice for the
colossus for the colossal